اشتري الان وادفع لها حقا خدمه تسوق جديده
نسبيا انتشرت مع نمو التجاره الالكترونيه
خلال اغلاق كرون هو نوع من التمويل او
الاقراض قصير الاجل بمعنى انه يسمح
للمستهلكين باجراء عمليات الشراء والدفع
على اقساط بدون فوائد لمده تتراوح بين
ثلاثه و اربعه اشهر وقد تزيد على حسب
الشركه شركات الازياء ومتاجر الاثاث
والالكترونيات وغيرها حتى تطبيقات طعام
ترحب بتلك الخدمات على منصاتها استفاده
بمعدل الطلب العالي حيث يتم كل شيء بضغط
او ضغطي الزرع الهاتف هي تجربه سلسه
مقارنه بالبنوك حسب استطلاعات الراي يدفع
المستهلكون عاده الدفعه تعادل 25% من قيمه
عمليه الشراء ثم يسددون باقي دفعات
المستحقه في جدول ثابت من الاقساط كل شهر
من الممكن ان تحصل من بطاقه تلقائيا لكن
على عكس بطاقه الائتمان فهي لا تضيف نقاطا
او مكافات على عمليات الشراء على كل حال
المزيد حول حجم هذه السوق
ونموها مع زميلتنا لميس ابراهيم
في عام 2027 من المتوقع ان يصل عدد
مستخدمي خدمات بي ام بي ال او اشتري الان
وادفع لاحقا الى 900 مليون مستخدم ما يعني
زياده قدرها 157 بالمئه عن العدد الحالي
واليكم مزيدا من الارقام
47.4% هو معدل المستخدمين المتوقع للخدمه
من جيل زد في 2025 وهم الفئه العمريه
الاكثر استخداما لتلك الخدمه في الوقت
الحالي 100 مليار دولار هو معدل الاقتراد
المتوقع لخدمات بينوكيليتر داخل الولايات
المتحده بحلول عام 20420
مستخدم في شركه كلارنس سويديه وهي رائده
خدمه تشتري الان وتفعل لاحقا حول العالم
531.3 مليار دولار هو حجم السوق المتوقع
لخدمات يشتري الان وصف لاحقا في 2005 2020
[موسيقى]
على كوني في الاستوديو تنضم لنا الزميله
سمر
بجانب الاقتصادي اهلا بك يا سمر يسعد
صباحك طيب لو نتعرف معاكي اكثر بصوره
مبسطه ما هي خاصيه تشتري الان
انا دائما الناس تسالوني ليش تضحك
بالبدايه دائما لانه نادين هي دائما للضحك
طيب صباح الخير شكرا
ههه ايه هو حلو يعني حلو الواحد يتبلش
بالتسعه
فمبدئيا مثل نعود الى سؤال سهام مره ثانيه
انه خاصيه اشترت الان ادفع لاحقا هي نوع
من تقسيط او ايمن سلوشن يعني حلول للدفع
الالكتروني اللي موجوده اكيد اذا انتم
دخلتوا على اي نوع من الشوبينج اون لاين
او التسوق عبر الانترنت اكيد شفته هناك
حلول عده تماره بيسبوتي هذول كلهم توفر
لكم انه تقسمون المدفوعات اون لاين امم
اربع مرات هناك ست مرات حتى تتمكنوا من ان
تكون هاي الدفعات اقل مبدئيا هذا الشيء
كان موجود في امريكا من عشرات السنين بس
كان على بطاقات مو اون لاين الان همم هذا
الموضوع تقريبا ب 20 20 اول مره ظهر حتى
قبل الكرونه والان ما شاء الله هي صناعه
كبيره جدا في المنطقه سمر بس انا عندي
سؤال شو بيستفيد مثلا الكريدت كاردز
بالعاده بياخذوا فوائد واذا ما سددت الدفع
كلها الامور بتضلك فوطه في البنك بس لما
انا انه شركه توفر لي انه ادفع بالتقسيط
بدون فوائد
اللي هم اكبر لاعبين في المنطقه في هذا
المجال شلون يحصل اموال هو ياخذ من التاجر
مو ياخذ من الشخص اللي من منك انت فهو
بيمسك لي التاجر اللي بده يبيعك البضاعه
يدفع له الى نسبه على المبيعات ليش لانه
هذا بده يجيب يسموه ترافيك بللغه
لانه
في تقسيط قامت تشتري اكثر فهذا الموضوع
ياخذ نسبه من التاجر وايضا اذا تاخرتي
بالسداد 14 يوم عليك يا غرامه تقريبا 30
درهم ثابته تقريبا واذا اجلتي موعد الدفع
يكون عليك تقريبا همم سبع همم دراهم على
كل مره جديد نفس الشيء اعتقد بالري
بالنسبه للسعوديه طيب سمر في ضل تضخم
اليوم في ازمات اقتصاديه في ناس يفقدون
اعمالهم الى اي مدى قد يتضرر هذا القطاع
مبدئيا في امريكا وفي اوروبا
مشكله بهذا الموضوع انه الناس لم تعد تسدد
المبالغ اللي عليها لانه ما عندها همم
مدخول او ان كان خصوصا بعد ان فقدت الجوف
سالنا المدير العام لشركه تعبي عبد العزيز
سجى قبل كم يوم
سالتنا ههه
سالت قبل كم يوم انه هل تواجهون نفس
المشكله هنا في المنطقه انه في تاخر في
السداد قال لا لانه شويه المنطقه كمان بعد
يعني الحمد لله ما زالت الامور اقتصاديه
لا باس بها وما زالت المدفعات اشتري
الانفع لاحقا على مبالغ بسيطه يعني بعدنا
ما دخلنا على حتى يعني ما زالت مثلا
محدوده يمكن اكثر شيء 2000 درهم مش اكثر
من كده فما زالت على مبالغ بسيطه فلم يحدث
تعثر في السداد بعد بس قال انه لاحظ هناك
تراجع في التجاره الالكترونيه
خلاص على كل حديثنا معك اليوم حجم الفرص
الاستثماريه في سوق اشتري الان وادفع
لاحقا هل هو بزنس مربح صحيح مبدئيا هذه
الشركات اللي عامله في المنطقه جمعت خلال
هل سنتين جمعه تقريبا ثلاث مليارات دولار
من التمويل من المستثمرين حتى يقوموا بعمل
هذه الشركات تقول لصندوق ستيفي هناك فرصه
همم فرص همم يعني همم استثماريه ب 95
مليار دولار خلال سنه بهذا القطع ما زالت
غير مطروقه هذه الفرص يعني هناك انه الناس
تشتري ب 95 مليار دولار وتدفع عبره او
سبوتي او الى او تماره او الى اخره فهي
تعد طبعا تجاره مربحه اليوم شركه تعبي
خلال ثلاث سنوات بدات تعمل ارباح الرضيع
يعني بدات وصلت الى مساله تطوير الارباح
وهي نسبه قليله ثلاث سنوات بالنسبه لشركه
مبتدئه تبلش تطوير ارباح فهي اكيد تجاره
همم مربحه شكرا جزيلا لك دائما